the more we looked into it
the more extraordinary it was they
couldn't find any evidence for a
connection with the food chain or the
market or anything
and
the more
the
experiments and work that was going on
in that one laboratory began to look odd
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantin kissimmee
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people a brilliant guest today and a
returning guest at that is a writer a
former lord and the author of a new book
called viral the search for the origin
of covet 19 co-author i should say with
an enchant very important yeah former
lord matt ridley welcome back to
trigonometry thank you so much guys
nadine great to be with you yeah i i
co-authored this book with alina chan
and she's the senior author on the book
but it's it's a double effort fantastic
well we've got you to talk about it
uh so here you are uh before we get into
it just tell a little bit about your
background your yours of expertise how
are you where you are
right yeah well i started as a scientist
um wasn't very good at it
so became a journalist
it was quite good at that i think but uh
after a while i uh basically became kind
of self-employed writer writing books
newspaper columns things like that
but always with a particular interest in
science um i got into the house of lords
in 2013. that was a part-time but
interesting career i've i've dropped out
of that because i think actually i can
make better use of my time now you
either do that properly or not at all um
and so i see myself as a writer about
science
well your previous book which uh i
really enjoyed reading as well was about
innovation and what i remember of that
interview we did it during one of the
lockdowns that we've had i think it was
the first look it might have been the
first lockdown and we had a great
conversation about innovation and at the
end as we always do quite casually we
went so matt what's the one thing we're
not talking about that we really should
be and you said something along the
lines of the fact that this virus
probably came from a lab or something
along those lines and we both went
oh [ __ ] because this was part of the
time when that was still being censored
so you thought oh my god we've had a
nutter on the program no i didn't
actually i thought oh my god we had a
person who has quite a reasonable point
of view that i think should be explored
for which we'll be punished that's what
i actually thought well it is staggering
looking back how
uh how very much you weren't allowed to
to talk about that topic uh in the early
part of the pandemic
it was shut down very quickly in
february march 2020 as a conspiracy
theory akin to you know it's caused by
5g or something like that
and
it's only
really in the may of 2021 that there was
a sea change because of various things
that came together suddenly the media
started saying actually we can't rule
out the possibility that came out of a
laboratory we need to investigate it
properly even the united nations sorry
the world health organization and
uh the us government particularly the
biden administration said very firmly
yeah that explanation does have to be on
the table and we've got to explain it
so to some extent were were there still
but there's been quite a lot of pushback
recently saying oh please can we just
drop this subject we better not you know
of course it was natural most pandemics
are natural so this one must have been
um we
i started out telling people no don't go
down that rabbit hole it's not out of a
lab it's natural i've read these papers
that say so i then began to think about
the arguments they were using in those
papers began to look at the evidence a
bit more and i said well i think it's an
open question it does need to be
investigated
alina chan and i
started writing a book we both thought
that within a few months it would
probably become clear that it was
something to do with that market but the
more we looked into it
the more extraordinary it was they
couldn't find any evidence for a
connection with the food chain or the
market or anything
and
the more
the
experiments and work that was going on
in that one laboratory began to look odd
before we get into that let me ask you a
broader question first which i think
sadly a lot of people will be asking
themselves and people like you and
people like us who want to cover this
issue
everyone wants to move on from covet i
think except the people who benefit from
it massively which is a significant
portion now of people online
particularly
why does it matter where this virus came
from is what some people might say yeah
i'm staggered by how many people
ask that question i know you're asking
it because it has to be asked but uh you
know
for me it's obvious why it matters and
you're right that apathy is probably our
biggest challenge
on this topic in particular
it matters i think for three reasons
first because if we don't understand how
this pandemic started we're less likely
to be able to stop the next one
second because bad actors are watching
this and saying
we could do a lot of damage with a
highly transmissible virus it doesn't
even need to be very virulent
and actually
the who is going to come in and say well
it probably happened naturally so we
wouldn't even get blamed you know so
unless we
pin down what happened we're encouraging
these bad actors and the third reason
which i think is important is that we've
got between five and 15 million people
dead now
we do owe it to them in some sense i
think morally if not otherwise to find
out what happened and how this happened
it's a great point and it's
when you told me about this that people
were saying it's not important i found
it baffling but let's actually now look
into the virus what makes you think that
there is a good chance the virus was
created in a lab well there's two main
strands to to answering that question
the first is the lack of evidence for
the alternative natural hypothesis in
the case of sars within a couple of
months it was clear that food handlers
had antibodies or were had the virus uh
that the animals in the markets
particularly the palm civets had the
virus
etc etc a very clear pattern emerged um
today with much superior technology
you know much better genetic testing
equipment uh we haven't been able to
find a single infected animal not one i
mean sure
cats are catching it now but they're
catching it from people you know
nobody prior to the first human
infection no animal had it
and no food handlers no chefs none of
the stuff we had with sars so the normal
pattern you'd expect and this happened
with you know with nipper too which is a
virus that was found in malaysia
some time ago you know the pigs were
getting it from fruit bats you know it
was very clear how it was happening so
none of that has happened in this case
and they've tested 80 000 animals in
china or claimed to have done and
they've not found a single one with it
on the other hand on the positive side
you have to take into account the fact
that the laboratory that was doing the
most research on sars-like viruses
talked from in bats
in the world
by a mile
was in wuhan
the laboratory that published most
papers on this topic is the wuhan
institute of virology the laboratory
that deposited most sars-like bat
genomes cells like virus genomes into
databases is in wuhan
that's not because this virus is found
in batch around wuhan they've tested
over 10 000 bats around wuhan and
they've never found a virus like this in
the bats there so it's not a local issue
it's thousands of miles away but you
know it it's it's
here's an analogy 2007 there was an
outbreak of foot and mouth on a farm in
surrey
it was less than 13 miles from the
world's leading reference laboratory for
studying foot and mouth disease at per
bright
right that turned out not to be a
coincidence
there was a leaking pipe at the burbrite
lab the contractor had come in to mend
it had gone straight to a farm nearby
and
and the cattle caught it there so you
know if if foot and mouth turns up in
purb right you don't say
um
well that's just a coincidence
it's pretty similar a sars-like outbreak
in wuhan is much the same
well this is one of the things that i
think i didn't i didn't know and i think
most people don't know is actually
things leak from labs
on regularly i mean not regularly like
every day regularly but they do leak
from labs right you would not be an out
of this world once in a millennium
occurrence would it correct and uh so
you know smallpox in 1978 in birmingham
brucellosis in 2019 in china infected 10
000 people as a result of a laboratory
accident now that's bacterium not a
virus but still
but the most striking
examples are sars because when the
science epidemic was over in
2003-4 um there were over that winter
there were
at least six we think cases of
laboratory workers getting infected in
the lab while studying sars one in
singapore one in taiwan and uh four in
beijing
and
in
in five of those cases
nobody knew how it happened so it wasn't
as if there was a drop test tube or a
punctured glove or something like that
so you know it's very easy for these
things to happen and
even in the best run laboratories you
know
of course most laboratories are safe
most of the time
but
there are inevitably opportunities for
these particularly something as
transmissible as this to be caught in in
a lab or in the field you know one of
the
ironies of of this work what the wuhan
institute of virology was doing
was
let's prevent the next pandemic by going
out and finding all the viruses that
might cause it in the wild and bringing
them back to a lab in a city to study
them how could that go wrong
well it's been described by someone as
looking for a gas leak with a lighted
match yeah
but but matt and that was because there
was an incident in 2012 which is key to
your hypothesis as to why perhaps it
could have leaked from a lab could you
delve into that a little bit please yes
when the virus was first described in
january of 2020 it was compared by the
wuhan scientists in a paper to a virus
they'd found in their own freezer which
was 96.2 percent the same
and uh that was very interesting it was
called ratg13
and i spent a day and a half trying to
work out where they'd found it because
they said it's been found in yunnan
there was no reference no link nothing
the name ritg13 didn't appear anywhere
on the internet before that date so i
said what's going on here they say
they've found it before but there's no
report of where they found it how they
found it and it was over a month later
that as a result of a an anonymous
tip-off to a an italian scientist called
rosanna segreto um rosanna secret her
name is um uh the that we were able to
link it to
the outbreak of a
pneumonia-like
viral illness that killed three out of
six people who caught it while shoveling
bat guano in a disused mine shaft in
southern yunnan
um roughly 1800 kilometers by road from
wuhan
which had led to
very strong suspicions that it was
caused by assads-like virus and that had
led to the wuhan institute of virology
sending
seven expeditions over two years to this
mine shaft to collect bats and bring
back samples one of which turned out to
have this
sample in it which they renamed just
before the pandemic which is a bit weird
um and it took another six months and a
brilliant brilliant spaniard on the
internet called francisco rivera
before
we were all suddenly able to say hang on
didn't you find eight other viruses that
are very similar in that mine shaft
and six months after that they published
an addendum to their nature paper saying
yeah we did find um eight other viruses
that are very similar um
but we didn't think it was important to
tell you about that so getting
information about what happened between
2012 and 2019
was pretty difficult
and one of the things that
they implied that they had only
sequenced the
new the bat virus in 2020 when the
pandemic started
but it later emerged
on the when they deposited the data on
the genome database it had a date label
on it which said that they'd sequenced
it in 2017 and 2018 so they'd thawed it
a couple of years before the pandemic in
order to study it now why what were they
doing with it they've never told us it's
it's important that we know this kind of
stuff it might be irrelevant and if it
is
they should share all the information
they've got but they've never shared
what viral sequences they had in that
lab after 2016 and that's what we need
to know and this is a point i think
because the chinese government have been
very very secretive and you know have
been obstructing investigations have
been outright denial and you look at
them and even as a casual observer you
think to yourself
there's something shady going on because
you're not being completely honest
well if
it wasn't anything to do with the
laboratory then the best way of
convincing us of that is to share the
database
of everything that was in that lab
there is a database it's got 22 000
entries in it
samples sequences
you know where things were found what
they were about 15 000 of them relate to
bats
it was available up until the 12th of
september
2019
for outsiders to check although part of
it was password protected since then
it's been offline
now the purpose of that database was to
help prevent the next pandemic
and so uh as alina puts it which
pandemic are they waiting for you know i
mean this is surely the moment you
produce this they say well you people
have been trying to hack it
what does that mean were they trying to
hack it in
in 2019 in september 2019 doesn't seem
very likely and um anyway what's the
problem with someone hacking it you know
it's information that you collected in
order to share with the world to help
prevent a pandemic so
why would you mind if it got into the
public domain
so
there's a there's a lot here that badly
needs answering um and yes scientists
were gagged right at the start they were
told in
any chinese scientist who published
anything about this virus was without
permission of the state was going to be
punished um so there's been a
you know far from being open and
transparent which they were praised by
the world health organization for being
at the start ironically um they haven't
been and
as i say
if there's
nothing to hide then don't hide it
one of the questions that this raises
matt and i think for a lot of lay people
like us it's really a question that i
think is important to address is
what is the benefit
of these laboratories doing this work
particularly when you're talking about
gain of function research which i think
a lot of people have questions about
maybe can you just explain to people
why are these labs doing this what is
gain of function what is what are the
benefits of doing that if there are any
etc yeah
well there was quite a lively debate
actually in about 2018 between one group
of virologists who said this is what
we've got to do we've got to prevent the
next pandemic by going out there and
finding the threats and studying them
and another group of scientists who said
that ain't going to work you're not
going to be able to find the virus
that's likely to cause the next pandemic
because you've no idea among the
millions of viruses out there which is
the one that's really dangerous and
actually you're playing with fire you
might make it worse so that you know
this was a live argument in in within
virology
and so what have they been doing they've
been collecting viruses in bats in this
case bringing them to the lab
sequencing their genomes
then they've been doing two other things
first of all trying to grow one of these
viruses alive in the lab
which is not at all easy you know you
get evidence that there's a virus in the
sample but it's not in a state where it
can replicate in in a human cell in the
lab
but they did manage with a couple of
viruses called wiv1 and wiv16 to to
so-called isolate or at least you know
rear the virus you know get it to grow
and reproduce
um which is you know a little risky but
it's interesting they did this at
biosecurity level two which is basically
wearing gloves and maybe a mask you know
it's not much more than that which is
probably not ideal
they they but then
for the ones they couldn't
grow in the lab
they thought we want to know how
dangerous these are we can sequence them
we can see what the the sequence of the
genome is but it's too fragmented to be
able to grow as a creature
so let's
synthesize
the the key bit of the spike gene
that causes it to be able to get inside
cells
and let's
stick swap that into one of these
viruses we can grow wiv-1 or wiv16
and then let's test how dangerous that
one is
these are so-called chimera viruses or
hybrid viruses
and some of those experiments resulted
in viruses that were 10 000 times more
transmissible between cells that's great
and some of them resulted in ones that
were three or four times more lethal to
humanized mice that's mice with human
genes
so these were significant gains of
function uh in the sense of you know
have you made the virus more able to
infect human beings um and human cells
and remember every time you put it into
human cells human airway epithelial
cells so cells taken from the lungs and
cultured in labs every time you do that
you're giving the virus a lesson in how
to
how to attack this new host and it's
gonna not just
stay the same it's gonna mutate and
evolve and say hmm
i'll try this you know of course it
doesn't i'm not trying to pretend it's
conscious but do you see what it's
called passaging yes you know and it
does adapt to to the new host so it was
very interesting when a few weeks ago
we finally got hold of the content of
some key emails between antifauci and
america and jeremy farah in the uk and a
bunch of other senior virologists in
which they all basically said there are
features of this virus that looks like
it might have been passaged in human
cells and we can't explain them any
other way
and this particularly relates to a thing
called the fearing cleavage site which i
can get into if you want but uh maybe
you know i think we can leave that there
but but the question you you haven't
answered is what are the potential
benefits of this kind of research i'm
sorry you're quite right to press me on
that um and so the the purpose of the
research as i say was to predict and
prevent the next pandemic no but what's
the mechanism the mechanism by which
that was going to happen was going to be
by saying
we've identified
that
this strain of virus is dangerous
and we need to start doing surveillance
for it we need to go and check whether
anybody's catching it in the forest near
the cave where we found the bat
and they even put in a proposal to the
pentagon to spray experimental vaccines
into bat caves in the hope that it would
immunize the bats which is pretty wacky
stuff frankly i mean i you know i can't
believe they didn't get the money for
that
hey francis are you worried about big
tech stealing your data i've forgotten
how to switch my phone on why doesn't it
have an on button like my walkman
never mind those of you whose technology
extends beyond the 1980s are rightly
concerned about your data being stolen
and sold on to third parties a lot of
this data is being harvested from apps
on your phone one of our fans has
designed an app called synthetic notes
and it is like a normal note-taking app
with several major differences that's
right unlike most apps it does not use a
subscription model once you've paid for
it that's it unlike most apps that will
charge you a hundred dollars a year i
knew that appeal to you synthetic notes
also stores all your data on your local
machine away from cloud databases this
combined with the fact that it is not a
subscription app means that synthetic
notes never needs to connect to the
internet you can safely quarantine the
app and it will still work completely
fine by paying for synthetic notes
you're buying back your privacy and as
someone who's tracked day and night by
uncle vlad this really is peace of mind
and it still does all the things you'd
expect from a note-taking app so you'll
be able to write a to-do list take down
notes for work or even write that
rubbish first novel we all have in our
heads that no one wants to read that's
no way to talk about my book go to
syntheticapps.com and use our code
trigonometry to get 25 off that's right
go to syntheticapps.com
and use our code trigonometry to get 25
off
they do talk in recent years
particularly more and more about
vaccines about the idea is
eventually we might be able to develop a
vaccine against stars
and a vaccine against any sars-like or
indeed any coronavirus
because sars-like viruses are only a
small fraction of coronaviruses um
so that you know the ultimate aim would
have been to come up with a
a vaccine
that they had ready
to stop a pandemic when it suddenly
started
now you can imagine if you were in
charge of that kind of research
how
horrifying it would be
to be accused of starting the pandemic
instead of preventing it so no wonder
they have a very strong incentive to
resist that explanation but even on its
own terms you know remember the purpose
of this research over the last 10 years
was to prevent the next pandemic well it
didn't do that did it so
but matt how is it and again you're
talking to an absolute layman here you
get this virus right you make it more
lethal more transmissible by over 10 000
times 12 times more lethal
three to four three to four times more
lethal whatever it is are you just not
you're not playing with fire here
well um
if you read the papers that are coming
out of the wuhan institute of virology
you don't get the impression
that they are particularly worried about
that
with one exception there's a paper in
2015
co-authored with ralph barrick of the
university of north carolina at chapel
hill who is the sort of godfather of
this kind of research he started that
kind of work
um but mostly on other kinds of
coronaviruses he only got into sars-like
ones with the help of the wuhan
institute and what that paper says and
xi jingle of the wuhan institute of
viralgie as a co-author on it says
hang on a minute some of these
experiments are dangerous and we do need
to stop and think about whether they're
worth the risk and this
2015 is key because that's right in the
middle of a of a very live debate in the
u.s about gain of function
which was started by some influenza
experiments a guy called ron faucio in
the netherlands and uh another team in
wisconsin
had done these experiments in which they
turned a bird flu into a mammal flu
effectively they you know they right
they made it possible for ferrets to
give flu to other ferrets
a flu that previously could only be
um transmitted from bird to bird through
the air not you know an aerial infection
the experiment was done in incredibly
safe conditions huge amount of
preparation to make sure that it was
safe and the the answer it gave was
it's much easier for this virus to turn
into a mammal
flu than we thought
so that's a warning and we're glad we
did the experiment said that we know
that
but there was a bunch of other
scientists who said
should you really be doing this i mean
didn't we know it was possible for this
to happen
what if it were to escape you know how
dangerous would that be you've basically
trained
a virus to attack mammals which it
wasn't
expecting to do
so that's what the gain of functioning
pause was all about a pausing federal
funding between 2014 and 2017 saying
let's not fund these kinds of
experiments and let's not publish the
details of how we did them so that other
people can't pick up on them and then in
2017
under donald trump but was it anthony
fauci who wanted it changed because he'd
always argued against the pause we don't
know
that the pause was ended
but meanwhile during the pause
some american money had gone to fund
similar experiments
in wuhan
this is something i'm francis i'm just
sorry i just want to pick up on this one
point which is i know this isn't
strictly about the virus but it is about
the other stuff
can you
again to the layman
and me
why
why are the united states
funding research of this kind in china
how does this why is this this thing
happening aren't countries like do you
sure i'm getting that
yes and and the answer which is
superficially sensible um is that
emerging
pandemics are not going to come out of
north carolina yeah they might but you
know not necessarily
there's every chance they're going to
come out of tropical regions
particularly forested regions places
lots of bats the the bats as a source of
dangerous viruses has clearly come up
the agenda in the last 20 years because
ebola is in bats nippers and bats
hendras from bats rabies is from bats
you know there's bats bats seem to carry
a lot of diseases that might spark
pandemics
um
so let's go to where they're
where these viruses live and let's study
them
and
let's fund
researchers in those countries to
to work on them so there's an
organization called the eco health
alliance which is a new york based
foundation which grew out of a wildlife
charity founded by gerald darrell
funnily enough
and very entrepreneurially a guy called
peter dazak spotted this opportunity and
said in the wake of sars there's
suddenly a lot of money
um
for
uh this project of going out and looking
for infected animals in the wild
and so he started getting huge american
government grants and distributing them
to partners in other parts of the world
and his biggest partner was the wuhan
institute of virology and one of his
best friends was xi jing li the head of
the key laboratory there and they went
on many expeditions together
to bat caves and don protective
equipment and caught bats and things
like that so it's very much a
collaboration
and remember scientists love
international collaborations and you
know they think it's a good idea
but
the the paper that describes
some of these chimeric virus experiments
that resulted in
greater infectivity
by ben who and colleagues 2017
clearly acknowledges an american grant
now that wasn't a big part of the
funding it was quite a small part of the
funding most of the money came from the
chinese academy of sciences but uh
you know there is no doubt that american
funding was going to this
not i think necessarily to get around
the paws on
doing the work in america
might have been a bit of that but just
because everyone is making an argument
this is stuff we should be funding
because we're going to prevent the next
pandemic
and i don't think they'd really thought
it through myself you know i personally
think i'm a huge fan of science i'm a
big pro biotech person
but i think scientists need to rethink
what experiments are going to
damage their own reputation if they go
wrong for us at the very least don't you
think it also betrays a certain
arrogance among scientists you know
playing with these things playing god if
you will
without realizing that you're human and
being human you're going to make
mistakes it doesn't matter how many
systems you put in place it doesn't
matter how rigorous the the systems are
the safety checks it's human beings
running this they're fallible
they're going to make a mistake and if
something like that gets out well we're
going to be even even more problems than
we are already
yeah and
you know ralph barrack who as i say is
the kind of godfather of this has has
been
uh implicitly critical of the fact that
some of these experiments were being
done at low biosecurity levels
china was in the process of building its
first biosecurity level four lab during
these years what does that mean
[Laughter]
okay well biosecurity levels take us
through all the levels yeah bicycle
security level two you're wearing gloves
probably a mask you're being a bit
careful because i've been in central
london exactly exactly
um
uh
biosecurity level and that's the level
they they did experiments on cells on
yeah when they went to infecting live
mice with viruses they went up a level
to biosecurity level three now what
that's doing is you've got a cabinet
with negative air pressure so that you
know the air is sort of going in and not
coming out at you
and you're working on them in with
gloves that are sort of built into the
cabinet yes yeah okay so that's pretty
good yeah and you've seen that barista
level four
you're doing that but you're also
wearing a spacesuit
and the spacesuit has positive air
pressure in it so you you know you
inflate like the michelin man and that's
so that if you puncture your suit
the air goes out not in so nothing can
get into you and you shower
before you take the suit off and you
shower after you take the suit off and
you then put your clothes on so your
clothes have not even been in the lab
etc etc and the lab has no sharp edges
and it has no corners in which you can't
clean and things like that so and and
the the air handling is absolutely
critical so these are really difficult
labs to build
and this one was built in wuhan with
french help the the french agreed to
give them the technology for how to
build it
um
the contract for which falling off was
signed by a man called michelle barnier
when he was
french foreign secretary um and
but the french then got very annoyed
because the chinese having got the
engineering details basically said well
we're not going to involve any french
firms and we're not going to invite any
french scientists after all we're just
going to do it ourselves so that doesn't
sound like them big row about that
but
when these when ben who's paper came out
the american embassy sent some experts
to wuhan saying could we come and have a
look around because
you've asked for help from the
university of texas galveston medical
branch
to improve the functioning of this
biosecurity level 4 lab
um we'd love we'd like to come and you
know see
see around and they wrote a pretty
scathing report saying the procedures
are not good the training is not good
the
equipment is is not as good as it should
be and that was in 2018 so there were
concerns
but it's not necessarily relevant to
this story because the experiments that
i'm talking about were done at barrister
level three and two and they were done
on the old
campus of the wuhan institute of
virology which is about 10 miles from
the new campus when the world health
organization team went a year ago pretty
well exactly
to wuhan they only visited the new
campus they didn't go to the campus
where these experiments were actually
done
right well i do think it's relevant
actually matt because as again as a
layman it just sounds to me like you're
not dealing with a counterparty in china
that has the same attitude to this level
of safety that you might do elsewhere
and as a russian i'm allowed to say this
not not all of the world operates and
thinks exactly like we do here in the
west right and attitudes to safety
attitudes to care attitudes to precision
of engineering not quite the same in in
some countries as they are another so i
think what it may be that it didn't
happen there might have happened
elsewhere but i think what it speaks to
is the fact that these are not
necessarily people that can be trusted
with this level of threat
well yes and we've got to be careful
here these are perfectly good scientists
doing sure pioneering work and uh the
technology in engineering is as good as
many places in the world but of course
it may not be quite the particularly if
you're if you're you know the off this
is your first foray into this kind of
level of work but just going back to to
to the to a russian example
there was an out the city called
swedlosk now at caterinburg where um
about 68 people died suddenly um
and there's a plant in the
city that
the west said was a bio warfare plant
could it have been a leak of anthrax
the soviets said don't be ridiculous
they died of food poisoning
um
and we've investigated forget it
and so the americans said well
could we send matt meselson a nobel
prize winner and a bunch of other people
to to to confirm what you've said this
is the this is 1979 was the incident
um uh meselson and co went they said
the russians are right there's nothing
to see here
the soviet union then collapsed
and some of the scientists who worked in
that bio-warfare plant and it was a
bio-warfare plant then came forward and
said actually that was a leak it was
anthrax that killed 68 people we left a
filter off an exhaust pipe and we left a
note for the next shift saying remember
to put the filter back on before you do
it and they didn't read the note and we
sent a bloom of anthrax over a suburb
um so it took a change of regime yes
before we found out what really happened
well this is my point i wasn't trying to
insult scientists who are doing the work
or whatever i just know
that kind of regime
right and the chinese communist party
does not seem to me to be a million
while miles away from the party under
which i lived the early part of my life
these are people by and large who will
do everything to cover up the truth if
it means not losing face in in in the
west
and to avoid responsibility for things
they've done that doesn't mean they are
responsible
but i certainly don't have a lot of
faith or trust in that kind of
institution we tell us a slightly
amusing story in our book um about a
leak that happened in may 2020 in
central china
and this was a leak of
leopards okay
there was a guy out in this field one
day
on the edge of a city i kind of which
city in china and suddenly there's a
leopard sitting in his field and he goes
whoa i've just seen a leopard now you
can't see the leopard there's no
leopards around here you know i saw a
leopard and somebody else says i've seen
a leopard and suddenly there's all this
you know people are seeing leopards
and um
he doesn't dare report it because
he thinks well i'll probably get told
off if i report this
uh but eventually the news reaches a
media organization which ring up the
local zoo and said have you lost any
leopards no no we haven't lost any
leopards
and
more sightings more leopards they ring
them back and say have you lost any
leopards well actually yeah we did lose
some leopards
why have you seen them you know and but
the point is
nobody wanted to own up yeah
and under that kind of regime that
happens you know there is no uh there's
no upside
to blowing a whistle no then there's no
transparency as a result but that makes
me think matt
everything that you have said everything
that we've talked about
means in my mind it's inevitable that
this is going to happen again
well one thing we in our book
argue is that there's not been much
evidence
of anyone saying
let's change our procedures
um as a result of this so as to make
sure it doesn't happen again that's true
of the markets as well
we're not seeing a huge crackdown on the
sale of wildlife in markets
for traditional chinese medicine or for
food um
and you'd think if that was the cause
you we we would be seeing that
um
and um
the one thing we have seen interestingly
is a change in the rules in china
to make the fines for selling
experimental animals in the market
bigger
okay so if if you want to market some if
you want to
take mice home at the end of your shift
and
and and make a little money by selling
them for food in the market
i mean
don't look at me like that why would you
do anywhere
do you see what i mean yeah yeah then
suddenly they've put the fines up for
that okay why would they suddenly put
the fines up for that does that mean
that they suspect that's what happened
probably not
maybe they're just being careful
but
you know the world needs to stop and
think which experiments
whether this came out of a lab or not
which experiments should we revisit and
say let's not do those kind of
experiments
when biotechnology started in the mid
1970s
scientists got together at a place
called azillamar in california
and said let's draw up some rules to
reassure the world that we're not going
to do crazy stuff with this new genetic
engineering
and one of the rules they came up with
was we shouldn't work on highly
pathogenic organisms
we should you know we should work on e
coli and
which is mostly a friendly organism and
there is a disease you can get from e
coli but you know they were saying don't
let's work on the pathogenic strains
let's work on the safe strains
well they quite in those days all about
bacteria you know it wasn't about
viruses
but you know
when did that change and how far did we
go to the point where we're doing
risky experiments with dangerous viruses
i mean i i consider myself well educated
in genomics and biotechnology although
i'm no
great expert
i didn't know this kind of work was
going on until the pandemic started and
i think i'd have been quite shocked if
i'd read some of those papers and seen
how
much a sars-like virus had been
increased in infectivity or virulence
and
the fact that i find even more worrying
is that it seems to be business as
normal but there's another way that we
can create a type of pandemic virus it's
the way that we keep animals when we
transport them particularly things like
chickens etc how much of a danger is
that
yeah well
um
there was a there was a a crash on a
freeway in america last week um and all
these
cardboard boxes were all over the
freeway they contained monkeys live
monkeys
that were being transported from a port
where they'd been imported from
mauritius
to be used in experiments in a lab
somewhere
and luckily the monkeys didn't escape or
anything like that but you're right
there's all sorts of risks in
the handling of animals there's no
question about that
um
i mean there's actually quite a
significant bird flu
epidemic going on in the uk at the
moment
it's affecting barnacle geese in parts
of scotland and they're dying in pretty
large numbers
as far as we can tell that's entirely
natural it's not come because of chicken
farms but if it were to get into chicken
farms it could be quite unfunny um if
you see what i mean so
you know we we
actually i don't want to sound too
alarmist here because i think
with the technology we have for
detecting things
with our general high standards which
are getting higher all the time the
chances of a pandemic getting going in
the human race are pretty low now that
may sound a crazy thing to say in the
middle of a pandemic but my point is
that
this one might be
a bit of an exception which was caused
by something that wouldn't normally be
happening like research of this kind
do you have a website or do you plan to
have a website well if you do then easy
dns are the company for you easy dns is
the perfect domain name registrar
provider and web host for you they have
a track record of standing up for their
clients whether it be council culture d
platform attacks or overzealous
government agencies he knows a bit about
that so will you in a second easy dns
rock solid network infrastructure and
incredible customer support they're in
your corner no matter what the world
throws at you unless it's your
ex-girlfriend in which case you're on
your own you'd know about that
move your domains and websites over to
easy dns right now all you've got to do
is head over to easydns.com
forward slash triggered and use our
promo code which is of course triggered
as well and you will get 50 off the
initial purchase sign up for their
newsletter access of easy that tells you
everything you need to know about
technology privacy and censorship
so matt what what should we
take away from this because
here's the counter argument maybe to
everything we've been saying and this is
just a devil's advocate point of view
but let's say that this way of doing
things this gain of function thing where
you create a much worse virus than the
one you started with and then you go oh
let's see if we can make a vaccine for
this and then when this virus naturally
occurs you've already got a vaccine
let's say
let's say this had produced a vaccine
that prevented the next pandemic i think
we'd all be in favor of that right so
what is the lesson here
well
um
that's why we need to find out
because
if it's just a gigantic coincidence
that this lab was in wuhan
but it had nothing to do with the
outbreak and it had the closest relative
of sarsko v2 in its freezer but that's
just a coincidence
and and it just happened to be that a
bloke was importing
um hog badgers from somewhere in a farm
on southern yunnan and
um he stopped in a roadside cave and
there were bats in the cave and they got
picked it up and he then went nowhere
else and he only took his pogba to wuhan
not to guangzhou which is where most hog
birches are sold interestingly um etc
okay i'm making it sound a bit too
implausible but do you see what i mean
it's possible that there's a perfectly
innocent explanation here that involves
the food chain and we can't rule that
out we actually have a chapter at the
end of our book making the strongest
case we can for that you know we say
things like
of course the scientists were studying
this because they were expecting it to
happen you know and things like that
um
where was i going well i was saying what
is the lesson here yeah what is the
lesson well if if that's uh the case and
it's a it's a huge coincidence um
then
we've had a lucky escape with the labs
it turned out not to be relevant
but we know enough to know that if that
if this virus had been in a biosecurity
level too
lab in an experiment
and
uh
the one of the researchers would be
almost bound to have got infected you
know it's so infectious this thing as we
know from our daily lives at the moment
that you really shouldn't be having such
a thing in a lab whether it caused this
pandemic or not
so let's have a real hard think about
how we regulate
uh
experiments and let's also have a real
hard think about how transparent we are
after
a pandemic starts because it's not good
enough to have all this secrecy um yet
again like we had with sars
when an airliner crashes
the information from the black box and
other sources is shared all across the
industry everybody gets to know what
happened so that you can learn the
lessons
it feels to us like that ought to happen
in these cases if there's an incident in
a lab because somebody punctures a glove
there ought to be an automatic will
every lab in the world gets to hear
about how that happened without
wanting to send the guy to jail for
puncturing his glove just saying
beware we've discovered that you know
it's not sensible to have hypodermic
needles
next to
gloves or whatever it might be you know
you know because that's what you do in
the airline industry you say we've
discovered a little glitch that we
didn't realize was risky but it is
let's do that but but isn't this the
central flow of the argument which is
i think we can all accept we can't trust
the ccp they're not going to be honest
they're not going to be forthcoming
so this is just going to happen again
isn't it because we're never going to
learn these lessons well but what if
america britain australia
european countries japan all got
together and said here's a treaty in
which we all agree to share information
when this kind of thing happens
we share every incident from every lab
in our countries with you
everybody who signs this treaty gets to
hear about what happens at purbrite when
we have a leaking pipe with a foot and
mouth um virus in it
um
and more and more countries sign it
eventually we shame china into signing
it now i don't know how you do that
that's that's way above my pay grade but
do you get the point you know that a
pandemic treaty that we build up in that
way might be the way of
making sure that even communist regimes
are shamed would the soviet union have
signed a treaty like that
that's my question you told me no
no way
there is no way a regime like that would
share all of their secrets particularly
their mess-ups
no but it does at least put some
pressure on them it does at least show
you know it shines up the fact that
they're not collaborating not
cooperating
maybe if it came with not giving the
money to do it anymore and whatever but
i guess what i'm hearing is
you you're not suggesting a blanket ban
on this type of research you're saying
it should be done in a more secure lab
there should be more supervision there
should be more transparency after the
fact that's your that's your position
well i'd go a little bit further than
that i'd say let's not do gain of
function experiments on uh dangerous
viruses that are related to viruses that
could cause human disease
yeah i mean there's also lots of
chemical and biological weapons that are
completely banned that are being
researched in russia in china at the
moment so
yeah it's great news all around me yeah
the future's bright the future is uh
pandemic yeah the future is one giant
pathogen um yes
let me make a slightly optimistic point
which is that when this started there
was a lot of stuff about how this is
you know
our own punishment for re
raping the earth you know and there's a
sort of ecological angle to this yeah um
and i pointed out that actually the one
place that isn't deforesting because
deforestation is the key link here um
the one place that isn't deforesting
well lots of places aren't but the place
that's reforesting faster than almost
anywhere on the planet is southern china
actually there's an enormous growth in
the amount of green vegetation in that
area people are leaving
the countryside and going into the
cities abandoning farms they're getting
overgrown with vegetation et cetera this
is a huge trend
so if anything the problem is too much
forest and too many bats it's not that
we're destroying their habitat and
they're all having to move into town
these bats don't live in buildings
anyway they live in caves
horseshoe bats do mostly um so
if this turns out to be an exception as
a result of a
human error
then in some ways it's reassuring in the
sense that all we have to do is not do
the human error
and we might not get a future pandemic
matt isn't the problem gonna be and look
you're an optimist i'm a miserable
pessimist
isn't the problem gonna be that we're
never going to find out
alina and i both take the view that we
will eventually find out
we think enough people know
one way or the other you know
there might be information about the
market that hasn't come out there might
be information about the lab that hasn't
come out
but at some point maybe after the fall
of xi jinping's regime
somebody's going to come forward and say
here's what happened
that we've there must be people who
could blow the whistle and tell us more
now at the moment it's far too difficult
for them to do so and we're probably not
welcoming enough for them in the west
alina makes this point quite often you
know we need to as it were roll out the
red carpet for somebody who comes and
talks
but i think
it's amazing how stuff does eventually
trickle out and we're having a constant
trickle at the moment i mean we you know
we had a key document break in september
another one just a few weeks ago
um
you know here's a little story that that
happened in uh in november
there's a paper came out from a french
group saying we've found a very similar
virus in bats in laos it's slightly more
similar than that one from the the mine
which if it's flitting around in bats in
laos that slightly takes the wuhan
institutology off the hook doesn't it
um and i pointed out that yeah but eco
health alliance has been collecting bats
in laos and sending them to wuhan for
analysis
and ecohealth alliance tweeted
you're wrong we've never done that
and so i tweeted back well here's an
entry in a genome database of a virus
collected in laos by the ecohealth
alliance and deposited in wuhan
please tell me what i'm misunderstanding
here blocked and reported
pretty well not replied to um and i
repeated the question several days in a
row never got an answer you know so
the stuff we need to know
and it's not just in the china in the
west the stuff we need to know so
there's more stuff can come out
the truth is out there
matt ridley it's been great having you
back on the show i'm not i'm normally
more on your side optimistic but as ever
you've made me much sad about the future
thank you very much for that
listen uh the book is called viral this
the the the search for the origins
there you go i forgot the subtitle it's
it's it's a great read and very
important book and i i do hope you're
right that we will eventually get to the
truth maybe even before the next
pandemic
uh matt thank you so much for coming on
we've got as always uh questions for our
locals only supporters which we'll do in
a second but before that we have our
final question which is always what's
the one thing we're not talking about
but we really should be
i'm
i i think it's very
important that we
don't lose sight of the
big benefits of biotech
so despite everything i've said about
the dangers of of this viral research
i i'm not hearing a good conversation in
britain in particular about
the enormous benefits of doing gene
editing on agriculture on medicine on
all sorts of things yeah he said okay he
say here's my answer
why aren't we talking about
de-extinction more do you know about
de-extinction no no the idea that we
could it makes it far worse rebellion
[Music]
everything's fine there's more species
again yeah that's right what is the
extinction the the extinction is simply
bringing back the mammoth or bringing
back the passenger pigeon or the great
orc you know something that's gone
extinct
four steps
read the genome
done that in lots of these cases you
know we've got ancient dna from samples
we know what the genome of these
creatures looks like
second
take a living genome from a related
species and edit it so it's the same
third somehow get that into a living
creature don't turn that cell into an
embryo and then into a creature and
fourth release it fantastic so not only
are we getting the pandemic we're
getting jurassic park as well perhaps
exactly that'd be great that'd be great
yeah that's what we need some covered
infected dinosaurs
thanks matt brilliant stuff
all right i hope you've enjoyed this is
probably the last episode in the history
of the world thank you very much for
watching we'll see you soon or not
bye
[Laughter]
i should probably said that but there we
are
you